my name is Kevin Nealon and I feel
and I feel
I'm gonna try that again it's Kevin
Nealon right
okay
hi my name is Kevin Nealon and I feel
duped about helping Conan O'Brien oh
sorry help me how did you help me it's
with being Conan O'Brien's friend that's
subliminal okay subconscious you didn't
I didn't see you conscious you are here
to promote I wish I knew there was
homework I would have done this at home
all right hang on a second no no I want
all of this in by the way I want all of
this in I feel blank about being Connor
Brown I think that's the right answer
what is the right answer there is no
right answer okay so just what you feel
inside but uh you're an empty man you're
an empty medicine cabinet
you know
hi my name is Kevin Nealon and I feel
obligated okay you know I I do feel that
way do you really I feel like you do
have no friends uh okay well first of
all that's a terrible thing to say I
know you'll take it back eventually is
there any more print on here or do you
want to take that piece of paper away
from you
listen to me all right
you um
you often come to me and ask me for
favors and I always do them I'm you know
what you're is that true is that true I
every time I ask you oh he's going to
draw the line here he's he's not going
to do this and yet time and time again
I Met You in uh the woods to to shoot
your Kevin young takes a walk uh it's
it's hiking with Kevin thank you oh
sorry I think because subliminally I
wish you would take a walk
um to shoot this your podcast you had me
meet you early in the morning and you
trudge me all around the place and I
thought it was a real good sport about
it
uh
uh your thing is
sipping what are you sipping tell me
something I don't know okay did you you
don't think you you weren't a good sport
you use me you use me all the time and
then you you act as if you're obligated
to be here on the podcast today I don't
act like it I am obligated you no you're
here to promote your book I'm helping
you get to rock the book because I
thought you would have some nice reading
material here since it's so slow
I don't I don't know that you're a good
friend I honestly don't I know there's
pictures in there too if you don't feel
like reading okay
um we're gonna get to the book because I
have some problems with the book namely
uh it's all these iconic people in
television that you've worked with and
okay now he's doing visual bits uh let
me just got a visual bit at all yeah
you're having you're drinking coffee
with a straw while you drink water out
of a glass you can replay this you'll
hear it's audible oh it's slurping the
song the straw
um all right come on let's get down to
it here man you know you you think I
could stay here all day no I don't think
so I don't think you should stay here so
yeah you went on the hike with me I
appreciate that that shows hiking with
Kevin is premiering October 27th is the
new season four how did you think our
episode went
I haven't edited it yet but I'll fix it
and post you fix it I thought it was
fantastic I was you were good you lagged
behind a little bit if I recall
correctly well you kept making me stop
because you had a drone that you brought
that you operated to get overhead shots
you kept making me stop so that you
could unfold and then apparently for the
first time work this [ __ ] drone to
take overhead shots of us taking a walk
because everyone wants to see the top of
our heads while we walk through a forest
and then you'd say stop stop turn around
okay come back this way now come back
now look like you're looking to the
right now look like you're looking to
the left now come forward
foreign
and we were on a public path and it's
very clear that you're not allowed to
have drones in this area and old ladies
were coming by on their morning hike
and you'd say watch out watch out
watch out
and they'd be like oh always oh oh it's
in a hawk no no not a hawk keep moving
through come on let's go ladies it was
the least Pleasant hike I've ever taken
how dare you how dare I I when am I out
of my way to have a hike with you
because I felt bad for you and obviously
you had no exercise
no no the Drone is really a great
addition that's like you having a mic
for your show I don't see I'm not
finished with the you know with the
defense of the Drone okay
um the Drone is amazing and it's amazing
to to watch and editing I'm serious
about this because the guests are just
standing around like they're checking
their phone yes because you bully them
but you take a look you take a look at
you see the increased value and um
attraction to the show from the Drone
okay well it stops we got every time we
got a nice conversation going you would
say hold it stop unpack this metallic
suitcase
unwind and un you know fullness nice
conversation you're talking about we
would have we had some nice chats going
on I thought I thought we had a nice
comedic role growing and you can
you kept I think when I when we said
goodbye to each other that was a nice
conversation
[Music]
barely do that's right and then I think
you went and had coffee with the Drone I
think you you know where that drone is
you know what that drone is right now
where it's in some dumpster because I
crashed it I crashed it into a tree and
it was like a high tree and it was
falling hitting Branch by branch and I'm
thinking to myself as it's falling okay
it might it might be okay it might be
okay and there's one rock under that
tree one big rock and it hit that rock
and it just scattered everywhere yeah
well we should um
this is all hiking with Kevin hiking
with Kevin's a terrific show it's a
great show it's a great show
um and you know it's I get different um
guests like yourself and I think when
you're hiking outside
people let their guard down not you
though but most people let their guard
down and they're very um you know
forthcoming yeah I had trouble putting
my guard down because I kept dodging the
Drone as it caught very close to my face
do you want to hear a true story finally
yeah sure
okay forget it no no let's let's go
let's hear it I was talking with Kim
Basinger and I almost flew the Drone
into her face oh God can you imagine if
I had done that how fast I would have
been running out of there well that's
the other thing I think your instinct
shouldn't have been to run it would be
to help Kim in that moment and give her
I call her Kim because we're close
um and uh name a star I'm not close with
how many people do you know have you
ever counted very few now you've been
everywhere I've been everywhere and I've
met everyone and you
who do I know who do I really know I
mean I've met a lot of people but you're
not that friendly
uh
are you look at me I think I am looking
at you I think for one minute look at me
I think I am a friendly fellow I really
do Sona jump in do you think I'm a
friendly fellow I want to take Kevin's
side okay you know what we're gonna do
first of all you're not a fellow we're
going to
um
we're going to just pretend I didn't
throw it to Sona or is there a way we
can edit in a you sure are boss why did
you think that would turn out
differently I don't know I think I'm a
friendly chaparoo I really do do you
think you're a good listener I didn't
hear a word I
foreign
I think I do sure all right and you're a
good listener I'm a good listener I'm
gonna give you a date okay October 27th
yeah
2022 yep
what's happening on that date that is
the date
that you are doing something to help you
not just me but other people as well and
I'll explain okay go ahead no what's the
date first it's a day where Kevin Nealon
is going to do a lot to get his own name
out there and the guys of helping others
what is it what is that I don't know
honestly oh my God something you know
right
no to benefit it's hiking with Kevin
it's premiering the fourth season oh
yeah why do I even bother coming here
tonight again and we can drop that in no
we can't because I want to make sure you
just looks good no and yes I do hike
with people that are very nice to do it
and they don't complain or make me feel
guilty and it's it's helping them too
because it's exercise and I've I've
started so many people on hiking you
know people start hiking I canceled my
trainer to go hike with you and end up
standing in a forest while you assembled
and disassembled the Drone so I got less
exercise with you than I would have had
I blown off the hiking with Kevin show
and now listen people listening right
now are thinking these two don't like
each other and I want to make it very
clear oh my God not not in the least
sense I want to make it very clear I
look at me I love you I love you you're
I love you more if you should die today
or even tomorrow I would wait is it
today or tomorrow I'd like to know
hopefully
no I'm kidding I love you and I would
really I'm a little concerned about you
because I mean I'm not kidding around I
said who was I talking to the other day
do you remember
I don't I was thinking that Kona man he
just doesn't stop what is he running
from or what is he running to what is he
running to yeah what is it that you're
trying to do what are you trying to what
kind of void are you trying to fill uh
this is it incredible look at me I'm
looking at you I'm looking at you I
think that's uh an incredibly deep
question I think it's a fair question I
think like a lot of us I have things to
work out uh you yourself famously
don't connect you you often don't look
at me over the years uh you are a guy
that internalizes a lot how can I look
at you when I read about you all the
time and I see you everywhere posters
billboards
you know stickers Banksy pictures of you
on the side of like you know
broken down buildings
well first of all they put them on
broken down buildings because they erase
them if you put them on like a Citibank
yes I suppose I've become somewhat of an
iconic figure you actually you are
iconic I don't know when you die which
may be soon
um it's either today or tomorrow I swear
banksy's gonna do pictures of you
everywhere yeah I hope so and uh I hope
so and you're going to be a legend one
day not now some people say that I'm a
legend right now but don't you have to
be dead to be a legend I can be
legendary right now I think you can be
legendary while you're still alive yeah
legendary but a legend you think sure
yeah and well how so well oh God he's
taking another sip you know it's uh it's
official this is a audio medium and
you're doing visual [ __ ] I'm not looking
for Laughs I'm just behaving as as I
would you know in front of an iconic
legend I
um I give you every opportunity I try
and connect with you I'll tell you one
thing you do that I do find very
revealing
you tend I get texts from you because
you live around the corner from me and
the texts say
I'm hiking past your house right now do
you want to join me
but I don't get the text in real time
and you give me no notice
so you refuse to make a plan to take a
non-filmed hike with me you'll take a
hike and then you'll text me as you're
walking past my house it's not filmed
but I do have the Drone with me
but I'm curious about that I think it's
because because you don't really want to
take a walk with me you want to look
like you're making the effort but you
text as you're passing I don't think you
can make a plan to be social first of
all you say I'm hiking past your house
you make it sound like we're in the
woods and you live in a cottage you know
up in some trail okay but no I'm just
walking by your house that gas you just
had right now no what's happening right
now that was I had gastric bypass this
morning this morning yeah on the way
over kept this appointment to be here do
you know I was 350 pounds when I left my
house today but I didn't know that they
took the walls down to get you out hey
what about those people that are those
plus sizes that can't get out of bed
yeah that's rough do they build the
house around them is that how they get
in there no I think the idea is that
they gained the weight while they were
in the house oh I see yeah I don't think
a contractor comes and and builds the
house around them you don't think they
came in the garage
um look at me you know I'm
seriously tell me about yourself
my name is Connor O'Brien uh I first met
you of course oh yeah Saturday Night
Live yeah you were very nice to me uh I
famously told Lauren you're my favorite
cast member I never knew that yeah you
did I told you that and he frowned a
famous cast member you were my favorite
cast member cast member or stand up no
you're you're my favorite cast member on
SNL I told Lauren that he said which is
your favorite and I said I think I like
Kevin the best because he's he's very
take it easy I'm getting there
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you finally found a bar low enough good
for you